[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre l'usage
généralisé par le gouvernement d'outils
d'obstruction les articles 47 1 44 2 44
3 l'article 49.3 l'Assemblée nationale
et l'article 38 au Sénat pour faire
adopter votre réforme des retraites
injustes sans véritable vote témoignent
dans détournement manifeste et inédits
de notre démocratie après ces procédures
que vous avez cyniquement utilisé pour
bâillonner le Parlement une première
sous la Cinquième République vous avez
ajouté à la crise sociale une crise
institutionnelle vous deviez apaiser
mais vous avez jeté de l'huile sur le
feu vous deviez apaiser mais vous nous
avez insulté en nous traitant
d'irresponsables et de menteurs vous
êtes même érigé en membres du Conseil
constitutionnel ce que vous n'êtes pas
en effaçant la séparation des pouvoirs
je voulais solennellement madame la
Première ministre vous mettez en garde
ainsi que les présidents de groupe qui
cautionnent cette fun une stratégie qui
va créer une jurisprudence empêcher
désormais les groupes parlementaires de
déposer des propositions de loi qui
auront le moindre impact financier je
voulais vous rappeler l'article 3 de
notre Constitution la souveraineté
appartient au peuple français qui la
délègue à ses représentants nous les
députés ainsi que l'article 24 le
Parlement vote les lois nous votons les
lois le général de Gaulle expliquait que
notre Constitution c'est des
institutions une pratique vous ne
respectez pas ces bonnes pratiques vous
ne respectez même pas le père de la
Cinquième République la démocratie est
notre bien le plus précieux notre groupe
est de nombreux autres députés sur nos
bancs veulent la préserver madame la
Première ministre quand allez-vous
apaiser notre pays en laissant enfin les
députés voter la loi
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Bertrand pencher
vous portez à son paroxysme l'art du
paradoxe
premier paradoxe devant les Français
vous avez soutenu des candidats à la
présidentielle qui défendait la retraite
à 65 ans
et
depuis quelques mois vous êtes le
porte-voix d'une alliance contre nature
de la France insoumise au rassemblement
national hostile à toute mesure
permettant de garantir le financement de
nos retraites
deuxième paradoxe ce sont vos alliés de
la nupes qui sur instruction du leader
de la France insoumise au sciemment
empêché l'assemblée de débattre et de
voter sur le cœur de la réforme
[Musique]
et vous prétendez maintenant avec cette
proposition de loi que ce débat pourrait
se tenir en quelques heures monsieur le
président Bertrand penchère vous le
savez et monsieur le député de Courson
grand défenseur de la rue rigueur
budgétaire le 7 aussi votre proposition
de loi est inconstitutionnelle elle
aggraverait lourdement les charges
publiques réduiraient les recettes elles
méconnais frontalement l'article 40 de
notre Constitution et avec vos alliés
insoumis vous persévérez dans une
deuxième atteinte à notre constitution
de contrôle de la recevabilité a été
dévoyé à des fins uniquement partisanes
et aujourd'hui dans une nouvelle
atteinte au principe même de notre
démocratie vous prétendez
ignorer un vote clair et net en
commission des affaires sociales qui a
abrogé le premier article de votre
proposition de loi
alors cette proposition de loi sera
débattue jeudi en séance publique je ne
vais ni anticiper ni présenter ces
débats à venir mais ils doivent avoir
lieu dans le cadre fixé par notre
Constitution Gaston monerville que vous
aimez citer disait que Violet la
Constitution s'est attentée au droit
même des citoyens alors monsieur le
Président pencheur la démagogie permet
de faire les gros titres mais elle
conduit aux déceptions au colère et au
rejet de la politique comme de nos
institutions alors respectez la
Constitution respecter les 100 175
heures de débat parlementaires respectez
le vote des députés en commission
monsieur le Président pencheur mettait
enfin vos actes en cohérence avec vos
propos
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
ment
madame le Premier ministre vous deviez
apaiser le pays vous continuez à jeter
de l'huile sur le feu tout ça n'est pas
responsable
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]